sur la place de l'église saint-pierre à
plaisir un géomètre expert est en train
de prendre les mesures de sept places de
parking pour personnes à mobilité
réduite
tous les géomètres experts de france
mesure de la même façon on va faire une
première mesure en fait à l'extérieur
des places où on rentre un code pour
préciser que cette mesure c'est une
mesure à l'extérieur de la place on
comprend une première mesure en tout pas
moins de six mesures vont être prises
les quatre coins de la place un point à
l'extérieur et le prend d'entrée de la
place les 1800 géomètre expert français
organise l'opération nationale blue
parking à l'occasion de la journée
mondiale de handicap vendredi 3 décembre
le but relever les places pmr avec une
précision centimétrique pour faciliter
ensuite le stationnement des prochaines
voitures autonomes et ainsi rendre plus
simple le quotidien des personnes
handicapées l'étape suivante en fait
nous on va récupérer notre fichier sur
ordinateur et on va le transmettre en
fait au site j'ai au foncier point fr
donc un site qui est gérée par leur des
géomètres experts dans lequel ils vont
intégrer toutes les places sur le site
pour qu'ensuite ça soit diffusé en open
data et que tout le monde puisse y avoir
accès il faut à peu près deux minutes
pour prendre la mesure d'une place le
métier de géomètre expert est encore
méconnu il regroupe plusieurs domaines
d'activité ont fait du bornage on
délimite les propriétés ont fait des
relevés topographiques ont fait des
relevés d'architecturé ont fait des
relevés
des copropriétés des moments c'est très
varié on travaille sur le terrain bien
sûr en informatique dans les yvelines
seulement 30 géomètres experts sont en
activité il manquerait sur le territoire
national plus de 4000 assistant
technicien technicien ou encore
ingénieur